so I'm going to talk about a little bit
about architecture and to just preface
that I was a visiting professor at the
Bartlett School of Architecture in UCL
and I continue to be for about four
years and you know you hang out there
and you talk to people and I was
interested in interactivity and so I
started talking with the architects
about what they thought about
interactivity now many of them make
installations and so on but those aren't
necessarily wildly different from other
kinds of interaction but when I was
talking to Alan Penn who's the head of
the five schools he said well you know
architecture is all about social
interaction it's it's all about social
interaction and and and then I said well
what do you think an interface is and he
said well you know if you open the door
it's a different interface idea open the
door it's a different interface in ours
then of course you know I thought about
that for about 30 days and then I began
to understand it and it was in what
light of thinking about that question
what is an interface for architecture
that I then inquired more deeply into
the nature of interactivity in general
and interfaces in general and what I'm
going to present today is the first
effort at talking about some of these
things in a talk although I did write a
very long paper that is much too long on
the general topic of architecture and
HCI so there are countless forms of
interaction and countless forms of
interact of interfaces but when you're
the interested in designing those you're
typically it have some special thoughts
in mind like controlling something now
architecture and HCI often differ in
that architecture is about how people
dwell in things and HCI is often a lot
about control or nuance or something
about your relation to the artifacts but
nonetheless there are interactions in
both forms and the question is can we
begin to classify them in a mod and in a
way that is revealing and
exposing principles so in the control
sense you typically want to know where
the input devices are but not in all
kinds of interactivity do you know where
the input devices are and we'll talk
about that and you typically like to
know whether you are you're not
interacting but again you don't always
and that's can be a difference between
implicit and explicit interactivity but
there are other things going on as well
so in looking at this I thought they
were you know three fundamental kinds of
interaction that are significantly
different significantly different and
the one is so broadly speaking the
classical one which is inspired by
physical manipulation called the
recommendation then if you look at
contextual aware stuff there's a network
interaction and that's a different kind
of model and then the last one is to
what I'm calling the socio-ecological or
embodied kind of interaction and that's
in an architectural one and it's got
quite a different spirit to it and both
the last two two and three have been
under studied three being not studied at
all so here's simple physical
interaction
here's simple sensor interaction here's
what you have learned historically it
was interaction with the eight classical
thing here's one where people can
operate on the same screen but you know
it's just a tweak here's another one
it's a little more complicated because
they could be talking to themselves and
so on and then speaking over it and all
sorts of things although they doubt they
do speak and now we have this sort of
thing where we have on body stuff as
well as naturally the ones you're
actually explicitly controlling and now
let's contrast those ones which I take
are pretty familiar to everybody with
this
what's the interface here this is rather
active thing at the 2018 Benelli now
what is the interaction what sort of
interaction is going on here you can
stick your head inside that canopy you
can stick your head inside that canopy
you can stick your head inside there I
believe there's some mirrors somewhere
but what is the sort of interaction
going on there it certainly is one we do
all the time what's the interaction
going on
[Music]
it's not just physical right it's highly
social and there's so many things
happening here
it does go on what sort of interaction
is happening here so early architecture
what's the interface and now we have
another kind of interaction the social
interaction and why would it be hard to
imagine a robot in the place of one of
these people what's missing from the
robot that makes it hard to appreciate a
robot inside this social bubble and when
you look at it this is essentially the
main point that I will be working toward
by inching my way up to it by going
through the other things first they have
shared experience their shared emotions
they are the shared valuation if they're
in sync they have a shared sensory motor
engagement of the space because they're
cooperating coordinating themselves like
that and so for me this is this again
this social niche notion of interaction
I don't have a good name that is going
to be catchy enough but it seems to me
that that's the next phase of HCI and
it's going to be involved in sharing
spaces and once we think that way we
have to start thinking differently about
the nature of what's the interface and
interaction is supposed to be about that
means that people are engaged in joint
activity and the space has to facilitate
and coordinate well with the joint
activity there you are sharing epistemic
spaces they know what's going on with
each other they have a good idea what
the other person knows and they know
that they know it so there's a lot of
recursion about that for our grounding
things and common grounds there's shared
valuation shared emotions and there are
these shared very personal spaces so
when you're an architect one of the
things you're trying to design for is to
facilitate and you facilitate things
that are core human values like delight
in play and interaction or in social
interaction which is usually you know
values you're trying to facilitate the
experience and the execution of these
values in your life you're trying to
improve performance of course in many
ways but joint activity is a key one
because it's about social things and
then also to facilitate the complexity
of so
chill interaction which for instance
having rhythmic structure enables people
when you consider how could they debt
that that that pounding stick into that
tiny space unless they were coordinated
rhythmically how much more efficient
they can be if they coordinate
rhythmically so you can get more complex
actions if you integrate like that okay
so this this whole social ecological
embodied thing this type of interaction
is different in a few fundamental ways
from the other notions of both
interactivity and interface and that's
what I'm going to talk about so here's
the agenda there are three genus of
interactivity I say genus because each
one of course has countless examples
which can be finally differentiated but
don't gain you much by doing that there
are logical properties to these
interactions and that's something that
that when thinking about it I made a I
thought for me an advance was when I
started to think well you know
interactivity a be you know interacts a
be you can treat it as a relation well
any relation can be defined with respect
to symmetry transitivity and reflexivity
so by doing that I suddenly got some
leverage by using that as a forcing
function to throw out some ideas and
I'll go through that quickly and then
talk about some differences in
interfaces and then what's special about
the social niche and so on so here's
three types the classic network and the
one to be talked about
so the architectural one I'll deal with
the others in a second but the
architectural one is the one that isn't
really explicitly discussed I talked to
many many people at the Bartlett they
have something like 700 faculty it's the
largest architecture school in the world
and aside from the people doing work on
interactive installations who are quite
concerned with interactivity that
nonetheless you know is just they're
practitioners and they're theorists but
that doesn't seem to be a topic of
concern
so it's implicit in the discourse you
pick up some ideas but and one thing was
clear was what what Alan Penn was
emphasizing was the priority of social
interaction and the experience people
have that's what they're trying to
create so we have experience we see
social the importance of social elements
in some kind of design like this and the
importance of experience in a design
like this so the last one we could fill
out by having this architectural
interactivity saying well look a person
has situation awareness so when you
think about classical interaction you
don't concern yourself with the
situation awareness of a person the
person in classic case is going to be
manipulating an input device the the
system doesn't have to know the
situation awareness of a person doesn't
really have to worry about their perry
personal awareness what's happening
exactly around them they're in charge of
that the person's interests yeah so
context aware is the I was just doing
context aware design and I will go over
what makes Network interactivity but in
the case of well I'll do it in a second
okay I'm just characterizing these
things which are these these are
important concepts for this this other
notion a one way to look at these also
is to start asking about what is the
direction of adaptation so in the
classic one the people adapt to the
shape of the item people adapt to the
computer the computer doesn't
particularly adapt to them in the
classical one then in the networked one
which is contact aware context aware the
humans the AI in the system I'm going to
assume there's going to be I and all
these systems now they're adapting to us
at least as much and often much more
than we're adapting to them but the key
thing about the embodied interaction is
always this Co everything is Co
collaboration co-adaptation coordination
cooperation everything is cold
so here's the logical type so we say
well let's characterize them let's look
at them in terms of symmetry
transitivity and reflexivity so looking
at symmetry if a interacts with B then B
interacts with a that's the concept that
we're exploring now in the different
models so interaction is a type of
symmetric causation and I think what
differentiates interaction from action
is symmetric symmetry so we know it in
the Newtonian case where a acts on B and
B acts back on a or rubber hits the road
the tires thing but the interface where
the rubber hits the road you measure the
quality the interface by its capacity to
allow the traction to reflect the force
as perfectly as possible from the car
into the car so that's great so I do it
it does something back maybe it's
feedback but whatever it is is I cause a
state change in it it causes a state
change in me that's the heart of
interaction and it's different than just
action in the case of action here if I
am pointing and touching the book I'm
interacting with the book but if I'm not
if I'm just I mean okay allow the book
to just be resting on the table and I'm
just reading it some people will say
well you know readings a very
interactive process and you say well
really interactive or active so I will
argue that it's just active not just but
active because I don't modify the state
of the book my reading the book does not
modify the state of the book as much as
it might modify me in so many different
ways it's physically unchanged before
and after so and the dictionary
definition of interaction is reciprocal
so act of reading the wall doesn't
change the wall as much as it might be
an active process in me for instance if
I asked you to look at this
this is a very big process of active
active vision on your part all right
you're trying to see what the two are
and you're doing the various sorts of
things here's a little help and now you
can see that you have to really parse
them quite differently
okay activision is it interactive you're
moving your eyes they're sakata you're
doing all of those things but it's not
interactive so conclusion one is all
models of interactivity have to support
symmetry that is the hallmark and that's
why interaction is not just action
because it's symmetric to transitivity a
yes interaction should incorporate
symmetry state change on both sides
could be one shot could be continuous I
mean it could be you know repetitive
there's so many types of interaction but
within the big Genesis they still will
all support symmetry so here we have now
transitivity a axon Bibi axon see if
it's a transitive than a axon see right
now causation is not typically
transitive but it can be and that is
becomes the question when would it be
transitive so here if something is
transitive I can immediately operate on
something else I'm not immediately
acting on it I'm mediating the I'm
acting on it through a mediator so my
hand controls in a good way the
screwdriver the screwdriver controls in
a good way the screw the screw controls
in a good way the
penetration into the wood and does the
person interact with the wood that would
be mediate if you think that the person
interacts with the wood that's mediate
mediated and we could say that if there
is such a thing as mediating then we can
have chaining just as there was so here
we have the hand it's cause it's a
physical cause go down the one side the
physical caused changes something in the
screwdriver the screwdriver gives me
force feedback so that is no question I
can interact with the screwdriver with
my hand I can interact with the
screwdriver the screwdriver interacts
with the screw there's physical control
of the screwdriver onto the screw the
screw gives force feedback to the
screwdriver which passes on propagates
that force feedback back to me so in a
certain sense I'm now getting haptic
feedback which I could distinguish if
suppose the connection between the
screwdriver and the screw is not perfect
I could distinguish the imperfection in
the connection between the screwdriver
in the screw from the force coming back
from the screw which is propagated again
from the wood back up so I can
distinguish these different elements all
the way down to say the wood the screw
the screwdriver and up to my hand so
this would be a nice case where we're
preserving the kind of transitivity we
want of interaction when you look at it
that only applies when there's the
appropriate structural coupling so the
screwdriver is been designed and the
screw to to worked and create a
structural coupling a reliable
structural coupling with the screw and
the screw itself is designed to
penetrate the wood and did not wobble
around once you get it started when you
have the hand on that ball-peen hammer
the hand is controlling the hammer one
hand the other hand is controlling the
sander punch and if the Center punches
and you know also controlling it onto
the material so that we have a
coordination between the two hands
striking each other so we have got this
strong
structural coupling which means that we
haven't imagined we had those two balls
again the balls connecting and we didn't
have them on that support then one ball
could go off in any different direction
we wouldn't have transitivity going all
the way to the end ball it's because
they were so highly constrained that
they were canalized in the way they were
operating with reduced degrees of
freedom that we could have the impetus
from the one come all the way back pass
through the impetus pass to the end so
you've got to have that structural
coupling and an appropriate coupling
enables an alignment between your
intention to control something and the
execution so of course in the case of a
mouse we have a digital physical
interaction and a digital physical
interface you've got to cross it the
mouse enables you to cross it and
because it's supported appropriately
structurally coupled between the mouse
and what happens inside the computer and
on the screen on display so just to say
a little bit more about this mediated
interaction it's a kind of seeing
through process so the racket is the
mediating instrument through which a
player interacts with the ball but they
don't interact with the ball directly
obviously and when they're playing and
they have mastery of the structural
coupling to the ball then everything is
fluent and the racquet is transparent
and they therefore just think about the
ball and not the racket if they're
really good and they can enforce that
structural coupling of course that is
the challenge they only think about
where to place the ball and spin and so
the causation and control go through the
racket to the ball the classical white
cane people don't perceive the cane they
see through the cane - what they're
touching that's the original
phenomenological notion of transparency
is seeing through like glasses I don't
perceive my glasses I perceive through
my glasses although I guess I could
perceive my glasses but that's going to
be a completely different effect so we
need an adequate neuro scientific
account of the nature of this seeing
through but people are sort of working
on that through you know absorption of
tools and so on or when you have a laser
pointer you see through the laser
pointer right to the thing you're
interested in so the domain you're
interested in is the remote domain and
you're just seeing through like the
tennis racket to with the pointer and
way you make controls it's with respect
to the remote condone Ain even though of
course the Perry personal control is
very fine here the actual sense of
control is this magnification at the
other end there are problems with
transitivity though because of the
structural alignment requirement it's
hard to explain exactly what structural
alignment is or structural coupling is
so who's interacting with whom in groups
they're all close it could be
interacting with Bibi could be
interacting with see but as a
interacting with see when do people walk
with each other when they're in a long
march are they walking is front front
when walking with the back one how far
does that go can we get a definition of
this is this the vague notion this
alignment notion when you're playing
tug-of-war how many people can be on it
and still be said to be in kind of some
kind of a joint activity I mean you are
in a joint activity but what what
exactly can you say about the
transitivity of interaction so you say
well what about a system let's call the
structural coupling a system so now you
say okay okay do you think you're
interacting with the gears when you're
setting the time I mean no one ever does
it anymore but if you were setting the
time would you be interacting with the
gears well how about the car when you
turn the steering wheel you know there
has to be transitivity of
in order to get the wheels turned and
you know there has to be structural
alignment in order for the steering
wheel to reliably inform the position of
the car or the wheels so but do we get
feedback the way we did with the
screwdriver in order to establish that
we can register the presence of the
intermediate arts well if you were so if
you're if you're if you were brakes and
they made kind of squeaky noises very
subtle squeaky noises you might find
that the person was responsive or
adapting to the brakes
sounds whether they heard it or not or
some kind of squeaky things or something
feel in the steering wheel that actually
goes down to in this case the piston or
the some part in there looks like a
piston but it could be actually a gear a
differential down inside there a gear so
if the person can get an epistemic
foothold even if they're not aware of it
then in my case there is a structural
alignment with the appropriate epistemic
connections to have it come back to have
the force feedback from that particular
part as opposed to a fusion anyway these
are challenges so we could also say
explicit interactivity is when you know
you're interacting with a given part and
implicit is you don't know you're
interacting but you do satisfy whatever
the requirements are that we say they
are for interaction symmetry and perhaps
transitivity so just as I said if you
don't know you're responding to the
noises but you are then we could say
you're implicitly interacting with the
gearbox of the steering gearbox even
though you don't know that you are so
models of interactivity support
transitivity but only when there's a
theory of either semantic transparency
seeing through which will explain it to
us like the cane or the binoculars or
the the remote laser pointer and a
theory of structural coupling which is
control
bowling through so that means we have to
articulate these things if we want an
adequate theory reflexivity okay now we
start to march into territory people
never go and that was actually the big
benefit of starting thinking this way
was to come up to reflexivity so I can't
walk on myself but I certainly can hit
myself or scratch myself or amuse myself
or I can do lots of thing talked with
myself I can do lots of things with
myself so I can interact with a now
here's unmediated action on oneself this
is mediated it might seem like you're
acting with yourself but in fact the
mirror image be is structurally coupled
to a through the camera and through
whatever it is that's generating that
image so I'm interacting with the image
and it's structured no different than
using your mouse it just happens to be
that when I do this the the display
response is so familiar and related but
that's irrelevant so in this case it's
just ordinary transitive or just
ordinary interactivity
[Music]
each person is controlling their own
action and so they are interacting with
themselves in the sentence since I grant
you that this is a challenging thing to
make because by that token every time I
do this I'm sort of interacting with
myself except you know so there's a
delicacy here but I didn't do that no I
think it wasn't and it wasn't wanted so
the thing about the dancing is that each
person interacts with the other person
that's ordinary interaction it is dense
and highly coupled and it's fluid and it
has a lot of specialness to it but each
person is also part of the system of the
together dancing so they are themselves
interact they are themselves part of the
system so when they make a change to the
system it's a reflexive thing on the
system systems that acting on itself in
some sense and so you can have a
reflexive 'no sin this that you couldn't
have before so this is a little bit like
the scratching when scratching
themselves when you consider the person
now to be - so I'm scratching ourselves
we are scratching ourselves now you can
not agree with it or you can agree with
it but that that it seems to me that
there is a interesting tension in this
area here which would serve to
differentiate the nature of
possibilities of social interaction from
the other kinds of interaction so I
would say that most models of
interactivity don't support reflexivity
but human to human interaction is often
reflexive so that in conversation people
can make reflexive moves that change the
conversation and we don't say it's just
between them it's a kind of holistic
change that's happening
you can disagree because you say that
your conception of part-whole relation
doesn't allow that or you can say no the
whole is interacting through the parts
but with itself so if if I could make
this adequately compelling there is then
a difference in these forms like that
that only the architectural is social
version as the reflexivity so here's the
summary so far by asking about the
logical nature of different kinds of
interactivities or the sort of genus of
interactions we discover that there are
deep differences I haven't really done
much for your network notion yet so for
instance we can distinguish interaction
from action because interaction requires
symmetry some forms of interaction are
transitive we can talk about how far
they go because we are looking at
notions of structural alignment or some
kind of coupling conditions so that
means we motivate an analysis of when
those conditions are satisfied and the
special case of reflexive is interesting
in the world of architecture and the
social world so let's look at some
differences in the interfaces now so
here's classical one so in the classical
one we have a digital physical boundary
that must be crossed in the case of
social interaction we don't have a
digital physical boundary that must be
crossed we don't have the people are
part of the very interface but in the
classic cases of HCI that we design
because it's on the digital world you
have to cross the digital world so there
has to be explicit input devices whether
you know about them or not so there is a
boundary so the classic and easiest way
of talking about an interface is to
think of it as some kind of n
dimensional boundary where we can might
as well think of the different ways of
pew lighting things to be a 10
dimensional Orion channel boundary and
that we have a human side that we have
the other side and then there's that
interface with the inputs getting to
that and the outputs coming back and in
the classical account where we have to
cross the physical digital divide and
the goal of classical HCI
is to facilitate control of something
whether it was a power station a jet or
it turns out to be an application like
Photoshop the goal is to facilitate your
control of the things over there so when
we do away with the physical plant we
just are controlling the digital plant
which is the Photoshop application and
and now we want to be able to know where
the input devices are and we want to
know where the output is and the good
design transparent design is so to allow
you to understand these things very
clearly so we want to feel in control
and where control is explicit
intentional and transparent when we do
have that feeling of being in control
the input is intentional because we know
where the input devices are and we know
what we can do to the input devices and
if it's good and well-designed when I do
something here I can see the effect of
what I've done
so that semantic transparency and so I
have the feeling of direct control the
system typically is closed in that there
are outside factors that we just don't
consider as part of the system something
random happens is considered a bug
wasn't supposed to happen
and that only the actions on the input
side are actions directed at the system
if something else happens that change
the system it's not meant to be an input
so it's meant to be close to outside in
that sense it's meant to be determinate
and interactions with the interface do
not change the interface
I can move the mouse any way I want I
can stand in front of the camera any way
I want I do not change the camera I do
not change the mouse by using them
that's their job so we have to sort of
adapt to the interface network
interfaces so here we have all sorts of
things that are connected and the will
suppose that sensors like say this room
has got a few censuses I suppose those
are microphones so there are input
devices there are cameras I don't really
know where all the cameras are I don't
know where all the input devices are and
I certainly don't know where all the
output devices are so I don't know if
there's any voice control or gesture
control I believe that if I get up I am
controlling the camera now but I'm not
sure I had to ask so that's this kind of
world we have the on body sensors that
could be picking tracking us in ways
that we don't know we may not even know
that they're on us and then we have all
these outputs that we don't necessarily
know about and this is our life from now
on
right we all accept this is our life
from now on and now who's in control
here I'm not an explicit control that's
for sure because I don't even know what
I'm doing with respect to the system so
it's quite different and if there's
another person involved why there's so
much indeterminacy I don't know who's
doing what when and what the effects are
I don't know how they do load balancing
if there are a lot of people on the
network I have no idea how they're going
to solve that because the system itself
is going to have to determine how to
load balance and who gets what when and
how they're going to time slice it
imagine an operating system who knows
what it's doing so this is a rather
different kind of world this
interactivity here transitivity here
hard to say how exactly it plays out so
I'm unaware often unaware of the input
possibilities I act on things without
knowing it like the cameras plural there
could be sound coming out that I don't
know about it so I don't often know
about the output
possibilities there could be heat
controls it could be light controls in
smart buildings more and more all these
things are happening I never know all
the effects of my action and so I have
very limited intentionality a limited
sense of control and a limited explicit
understanding
I might implicitly interact with a lot
of things because in fact I do pick up
regularities that I don't know about as
an implicit knowledge of statistical
regularities and so I respond
differentially because of picking up the
implicit things just as the car but I
would be implicitly interacting like if
you had a person controlling a swarm of
drones where all the drones were hearing
with each other but they were the ones
who sort of you know had these gloves
explicitly so that would that be an
example of network that would be network
as well where you have a lot of sort of
quasi agents in there and whatever I
start here ramifies out there in ways
that I can't predict and then what they
do and back in return I have no idea so
that's one example the networks are very
broad I would expect it to be a much
more common form of study that we'd need
to do the interactivity of this whole
very much bigger genus than classical
HCI so many kinds are going to be again
the interactions with the interface do
not usually change the interface so if I
wander around yes the cameras moving but
that's the cameras job I'm not changing
the camera so I could there could be
learning an adaptation that would cause
a change like bringing more cameras
online or something but we'd have to
talk about whether they were there
waiting and so on whether that counted
as a change so the goal is essentially
of classical and network interaction are
in the classical one I control the
device to whatever degree I can and it's
supposed to help me do that
it increases my power because I can do
things I couldn't do now
the network one is gathering information
for the network owners and they're
partly controlling me though i partly
control it so we've got some differences
in the general orientation now compare
that to architectural interfaces so in
architectural interfaces we have
something like this so this space is
intentionally designed to support
different forms of social interaction
and work it's a Microsoft space possibly
in London now come back to the question
that I asked Alan about the architect
and so he says you close the door you
open the door they're different you say
how could that be a different interface
well if you think of the social
interface to be the constraints acting
on the people's social interactions I've
changed the privacy levels of the room
when the door is open somebody walks by
the door I see them so the social
affordances are different so I have
changed this sort of social bubble so I
was thinking about the serving hatch
which was a popular thing in the 50s
passaport a and French and so look at
these two different serving hatches the
serving hatch it restricts the the kind
of social relations you can have with
the person on the inside you won't have
a deep philosophical conversation with
between when you're on the outside
talking to the person and not just
because they're doing the cooking on the
inside leave aside all the social and
sort of normative implications of having
a person on the inside doing that sort
of thing and you contrast that with a
cooking surface like this where the cook
can participate socially in a free way
these are very different social
interfaces one is designed to enable the
full participation the other is designed
to restrict
full social participation so an
architect can have a big impact on the
nature of the social participation the
social activities going on in the space
by the way they deploy surfaces and
functionalities and so on so here I
think this is a simple idea of a social
interface and how it can reshape the
social possibilities of the space we
have when you when you design a space
like this obviously people are thinking
very much about the different kinds of
social coves are all coves and that the
spaces that people could come together
in who can see whom who can sit where
all these are these line-of-sight
considerations or the size of the tables
via the layout of the tables the benches
the bar all of this is part designed for
of course the nature of the social
interactivity a successful bar might
deform the shape of the bar is a
successful venue in a way that leads for
more social interaction of an intimate
sort maybe they would become famous like
that because it turns out people have
better social experiences so the space
of interaction and social possibility is
physically constrained but you know it's
a soft constraint very soft constraint
so here is the main point about this
again adding a wall can change the socio
spacial interface opening a hole can
change the socio opening the door can
but so can removing a table or a chair
it changes all the social exchanges some
social affordances and so would adding a
mobile phone or a group printer or a
water cooler they're gonna change the
social affordances we are not accustomed
to thinking about interfaces as these
three-dimensional shapes with things in
them three-dimensional spaces with
things in them but of course they are
and their interfaces for social
interaction and other kinds of
interaction so you take a room
and you say well how many interfaces are
in here there are so many possible
interfaces in here where would people
have a conversation depends whether
you're cleaning what kind of interface
you have depends how you're playing or
if you're sharing a closet that's a big
social interface and these interfaces
come into being when people are there to
animate the space so the people are an
essential part of this social niche
that's how I like to think of them as a
so as a kind of niche in the case of
niches ecolodge is a niche but it's so
ugly ecological niches they dynamically
change that I don't want to try to
understand what Anisha is and it turns
out it is anything but simple so when
more creatures come into the same planes
for instance the niche deforms that one
creature is living in as the others
apply pressure it's not just competition
for that those properties those
properties are defining the niche so the
competition begins to reshape the niche
so it's like Voronoi or bubbles pushed
together they deform as the population
changes depending upon the physical
attributes the consumption rates they
are not just a fixed notion it's a hard
thing to define an issue so they
dynamically interact these niches and
any given niche a social bubble that
people construct would change depending
upon how many people are in it who else
is around if they're you know related in
some way who enters the bubble and so on
and then removing these physical
attributes would also change now I'm
just saying these things but this is
pointing to a very different conception
of what an interface is and what the
nature of interaction is that the future
of HCI must design toward because with
the AI embedded stuff that we're going
to have it's going to be more inside the
world and it's going to be participating
so you suppose you're having little
robots in whatever fun factor you can
think of including your chairs
what are they going to have to do to
participate in this world now consider
consider this typical social interaction
for me this is a canonical example of
joint activity and some of you remember
it and some of you will do it and some
of you are doing it trying to dress a
kid and you know what exactly is the
interface
well this interface is different if you
do it in the big room then if you do it
in the confines of a closet so there are
different interfaces and there's
different socio ecological niches
because the physical spaces are
affecting the social interactions
they're affecting the physical
interactions and through their
constraint on physical interaction the
kid gets more cranky he hits his elbow
whatever goes on so what's special about
social niche interaction and the way I'd
like to think of it as what will it take
to get robots to participate
appropriately and by robot
I just mean an AI in stuff so it
involves other people not just physical
or digital things there's always a back
and forth and that back and forth is
more cognitively demanding than just
physical control their special neural
systems in the human body for this
humans have special neural systems and
you have to understand social intent but
it turns out that more neural equipment
is recruited than just understanding
neural intent I mean sorry social intent
looking at a video so you can do a good
job of understanding social intent in a
video but consider having a sort of skin
in the game when you're actually engaged
in the social interaction there is a
much more greater state of arousal I
don't mean just sexual arousal there's
other kinds you know social arousal
let's just call it that and and so
there's something else going on it's the
it's the game
that means that there's different neural
processes activated so now the robot
what's the robot got to do in order to
have this level of participation so we
have things like shared delight is the
robot gonna participate and shared
delight will you think the robot is
participating because if you don't think
the robot is participating in shared
delight it doesn't satisfy the
conditions because it takes - to share
delight so there's a sense of social
co-presence whatever that is that's what
the robot is missing
to some degree you don't get social
co-presence without a body with a front
and a back and then the people in that
space have this situation awareness of
knowledge of what's around it and they
share it and they know the other has
situational awareness and they have a
good idea of what their situation
awareness is and my Scituate so we
there's this cursive function thing
going on we have a sense of agency the
capacity for joint activity joint agency
there are emotions and we're always
affected by the others whether we know
it or not so among the things are I'm
aware of what I can reach what you can
reach so there's the peri personal space
and then the notion of shared very
personal space which is a a hardwired
sort of thing and and I know these
things about you and you know these
things about me so we have this
recursive common ground going on that
builds up through this social structural
coupling and this makes possible a
distributed cognition it applies to
emotion and I just want to get two
conclusions now so the next phase of HCI
will involve I believe a niche notion of
interaction it's got to be much more 3d
enveloping in the world
and this cocoa cocoa because unlike
classical interactivity and the
burgeoning network interactivity
there's no interface that we're on one
side of and it's on the other side we're
in it together that changes everything
the buildings and the stuff they're an
intrinsic part of the illogical and
social ecology but we have to see
ourselves as integral to that too
and that requires thinking differently
about interfaces in interactivity in
this world where we are all together
we're going to share things like
situation awareness that goes
recursively we know when people are near
us when another dog enters the same
space as one dog the brain alarms go off
when two conspecifics are in the same
room they know it very quickly and the
brains show it so you can be certain
that there are six very significant
differences I don't know what it's like
when a robot enters the room I expect
there's a lot of things that go off when
the robot enters the room but one of
them might be danger another thing so we
can also participate in joint activity
we feel or understand emotions in this
Coco way and we tacitly negotiate the
bottom line is that AIS will have to
infer meaning and not just third-person
meaning the meaning of being in having
skin in the game meaning and they'll
have to understand the point of activity
in a deeper way than they do and what it
means to be social cognizer and that's
different sort of interaction than HCI
or AI historically has considered thank
you
the questions how so David um this this
business of tango I'm interacting pretty
deeply with my model of tango and that
woman would heal it raises her leg she's
not interacting with her partner
she's interact it's almost like she's
scratching herself but also she has a
model of the of the audience very deep
and I think those things are even
stronger issues then then the
interaction in between I mean it might
be much more heavily undermined than
anything about that other random person
that happen to be playing tangle with or
the robot with the plaintiff okay so to
have the competence to perform tango
you're suggesting no doubt there's got
to be some truth in it you have various
sorts of cognitive models or cognitive
some things rules I don't know what you
have but there are norms that you're
trying to satisfy and senses of creative
possibility that are driving your
movements that interaction which occurs
as much inside the head or between you
and your body that's that's interesting
if it's inside your head for me that's
another kind of interaction I'm not
looking at that as hcy because for the
same reason that when I look at the
painting on the wall or I read the
document without touching it I'm not
interacting with the document I'm
cognitively acting on the document it's
very active no question about it I can
be engaged in active perception I can do
all of these things but one thing I'm
not doing I'm not changing its state so
that's a hard thing changing its state I
mean a heart in the sense of its factual
so I want to cleave the difference
between you know when you make a state
change on the outside and when you don't
now when people go inside the head and
they start to say system a is
interacting with system B okay so system
B let us
is the model they have of the tango
possibilities system a is their
predictive system over their normative
system of what I have to do there's
plenty of interaction going on that's
for the cognitive neuroscientists or the
cognitive scientists or the whoever you
want psychologists that's their job but
when we're trying to understand
interactivity for the world of HCI which
is going outside the person whatever
else might be going on inside the person
then I want this distinction because I
think this distinction is like a forcing
function that gives us some clarity on
some things it only answer some
questions little AG a she's not doing
that for a partner she's either doing it
for herself or for the audience success
conditions well beyond the success
conditions are external so she may be
doing it for herself but we tell her she
did it badly no matter what she might
think on the basis of the norms outside
so there are outward norms that are the
bottom line in a bit contingent way that
you know you just keep doing it wrong it
doesn't matter what you think you're
doing it wrong I'm going to have much
more conversation about that inquiries
in this well I mean the the values I
stated about way back about
I think they were back here maybe I'm
going to get to the wrong place sorry
this would not be the way to do it okay
I'm not going to find it those were
things like well facilitating the
people's values so in the case of if
you're asking as an architect what are
you trying to do I might wish to
engender a sense of beauty I might wish
to engender a sense of freedom I'm I
wish to and qualitatively improve their
experience now then you're obliged to
give an account of what experienced
design is or experiences that you're
doing not offering an account of any of
those but that clearly is an
architectural desire as well as of
course designing the space for its
acoustics for its visual capacities and
its comfort there are other things that
one could do and and so a good architect
it seems to me would try to canvas what
some of the positive elements of the
best theaters are of this sort and and
they would try to enhance those
production line so production line is a
good example of that if you have a
production line you can really
streamline the efficiency but the cost
is that the degree of freedom that any
individual has is much constrained so
yeah but those are post questions they
are all sort of instances of questions
that take place in the broader framework
there was a yeah okay
human Vegas Humongousaur beautiful
capabilities organizing and navigating
through space when you go from A to B
New York and London I can ask you'll
find it but when you create interactions
in thought space and when what are your
thoughts about using these capabilities
of the brain of navigation and mapping
and all these other things for creating
interfaces friend in a few years teams
of people disappeared enactment images
in space and thoughts in space and
spatial reasoning yeah so I'm going to
characterize your question to be about
the design of cognitive scaffolds in the
outside world so there is an open field
we when we people are learned interested
in visualization they're interested in
being able to get insight into some
process or some question they have by
looking at the stuff and interacting
with the digital things that that
constitute the visualization well
there's a lot of other possibilities for
creating cognitive insight that come by
scaffolding appropriately so you can
aligned paper can enable you to do
certain things that an unlined paper
gives you different opportunities so
there's a whole universe of questions
about that and now you say well what
about adaptive ones where we can change
it in tune with the person it's a
wonderful inquiry absolutely wonderful
but it is in the spirit of this I'm not
sure if it's socio but it's certainly in
the spirit of interaction with the
person but but in this case it's a
challenge for me a little bit if the
person doesn't do anything on it but
they just cognitively project
so suppose think of projection as like
augmented reality but in your mind so
that we have maybe ten thousand articles
on visual imagery but of those ten
thousand articles
almost none if any distinguished eyes
open from eyes closed visual imagery now
eyes open visual imagery imagine
you see a tic-tac-toe board on this on
the screen and I asked you about a
couple of moves imagine you don't you
have your eyes closed I ask you the same
question I've managed to give you a way
of you know asking that question without
begging the question giving you the
structure now one should be harder than
the other because I have a visual
scaffold to use even though it's static
it's just that's the empty scaffold so
we don't understand much yet the nature
of how to modify those scaffolds and
possibly in a dynamic way to facilitate
guiding thought or making thought easier
and that it seems to me is a wonderful
area I'm personally very interest in
that but a wonderful area and I think
you know it is in the spirit of your
question but one of the many things that
comes up from a question like that is
how to how to design the world to
facilitate X Y Z in this case X is some
kind of knowledge epistemic some kind of
inquiry values experience how do we
design the world to do that that is the
question of I think the future HCI and
design you know so what's the basic
question I think I'm supposed to say
thank you now
[Applause]